the 2021 state of devops report released
last year
it contained findings about how teams
navigate key areas of software delivery
we talked to two of the researchers dave
stanky and nathan harvey about the
report section on sre
were there any surprising findings in
the report
i was surprised to see how widespread
sre practices are
it's often been kind of believed that
this is something that's limited to the
googles of the world or facebook with
their production and production
engineering discipline which is similar
to sre what we found is that 52 of the
organizations we studied are practicing
sre techniques to some extent
at the same time there's a lot of room
for growth um among our elite
respondents
only 10 of them are practicing every
reliability engineering technique at its
fullest so everyone has room to grow
what did the site reliability
engineering section of the report focus
on
so this year for the first time dora
studied site reliability engineering or
sre and we looked at what practices are
being done among operations teams in our
study and what kind of outcomes they're
achieving as a result
sre is site reliability engineering in
my mind it always starts with that word
reliability what does it mean to be
reliable
at the end of the day reliability is
about whether or not your customers can
trust the service that they're getting
from your applications or from the
services that you're building
what did you find separates elite teams
from the rest
so the best teams um are the ones that
are really
treating reliability as a product
feature as an
aspect of their experience of what
they're delivering to the user and
prioritizing it accordingly we find that
it really helps to define reliability in
terms of user-facing behavior we don't
want to look at how do our machines feel
do their processors overloaded are there
is their memory full that may be
important operational data but it
doesn't define whether our system is
reliable for our users so
with sre and what the highest performers
do is they look at it to say is our
system delivering on behalf of what the
user is expecting
is it serving the user need and when we
use frameworks like the slo framework to
operationalize that so that we can
measure in real time the degree to which
we are keeping up with our promises to
the user
how can teams start implementing these
practices
the best way to apply these findings is
to first figure out where are you as a
team so get your team together get the
people that are responsible for building
the application for running the
application bring them together in a
room and together take the dora devops
quick check you'll find that at
cloud.google.com
devops
with this quick check you answer five
quick questions and really help assess
how is my team doing today
with this information in hand you can
then start to look at the capabilities
that are going to improve that
performance and of course we'll provide
some guidance on what those capabilities
are and where you should get started
next improving your team
what would you say is the core idea of
this section of the report
the biggest takeaway is that you don't
have to trade off speed for stability
speed and stability work hand in hand
together so the most important thing
that you can do is think about the users
of your service and make sure that
you're delivering the right value in a
reliable way to them
[Music]
you